are you garbage if your dad shoots
squirrels off the bird feeder from the
kitchen window
[Applause]
i don't think it's classy buddy
nothing like a tranquil morning they
hear gunshots as you wake up hold on
the best is he goes he makes everyone
shut up while he lines up his shot
shut the [ __ ] up goddammit [ __ ] i got a
bogey at 12 o'clock
he starts doing the military hand
signals
what's your dad's beef with the
squirrels man
the murdering of animals is the only
thing he controls it's the only time i
feel alive
when i got a chipmunk in my hands
and i watched the life bleed out of them
which uh what's your dad do for a living
you got a pharmacy shooting up squirrels
in the backyard
hachimachi
kept a couple of the pills for himself
nothing like a couple of quaaludes and a
22. am i right
[Applause]
it's a [ __ ] dead eye jesus christ
dude where you live are you allowed to
do that legally
no
that's the answer
it's a flamethrower so i'm pretty sure
all right there you go i'll give you
that clap it up for the d smith
everybody
starting it all [ __ ] strong baby
got 12 confirmed kills last week
all right where's edm
eddie
what's up bro how are you
not not too bad who you here with bro
nice nice and how long you guys been
together
okay
yo shout out to eddie for not even
[ __ ] faking it yeah
i don't know bro they [ __ ] come and
go man
[Applause]
that's the way the eddie operates
he collapsed under a second line of
questioning
eddie do you remember where you met her
at work what kind of work do you do
brother
okay
[Applause]
talk to me after the show my friend
now understand why your short-term
memory is bad but still
caught her stealing my crop man
i mean this is just is it garbage to buy
alcohol for minors than drive off to
watch to teach them a lesson
eddie i gotta be honest with you i
[ __ ] respect the move
i call balls and strikes up here that's
pretty [ __ ] good
that's awesome a weed grower trying to
teach lessons
[Applause]
hey man that's our beer you'll thank me
one day punk
throws him a business card for his weed
call me when you're 18.
when's the last time you did that eddie
four or five years ago how old are you
oh god that's
too old to be doing that at 25.
that's
did they say anything to you they try to
try to start a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
come back to my house to drink this beer
nerd
how much money did you score
usually usually
yeah he's got he's got a [ __ ] data
set on this
you're selling a cocktail waitress on a
good night i can make forty fifty
dollars if i'm really hustling i'll make
it
one time for eddie god damn buddy
denver's not [ __ ] around so far no